stop trying to imagine what your life
looks like down to the detail and just
imagine how you want your life to feel
like on an average Monday afternoon and
I was like wow that is so profound she
was like picture yourself at 50. what
are you doing on a Monday night what
does that entail because you're not
going to be thinking about all the
Milestones that you hit you're not going
to be thinking about all the successful
things you've done you're not going to
be putting the pressure on yourself to
meet all these certain goals instead
when you think about it that way you
just think about what kind of Life do I
want to be living what emotions do I
want to be feeling and you acknowledge
that there will be multiple paths to get
there and I think that that's very
liberating